the reason for the ever-expanding
lexicon of words that you can't say
which are often more accurate and we're
created by these ethnic groups
themselves
is because they want to be able to label
more people
racist homophobic sexist bigoted
here are five racist terms that aren't
that you think are racist terms now
before i get them i want to know what
what's the word that that's now
considered racist that you consider to
be the most
silly which are the terms that we're
going to cover which were once
correct by the way and not offensive at
all now considered offensive
which one of these do you think is the
most absurd example uh comment i'd like
to hear
some feedback from you now before we get
into this before we get to the five
there are obviously
some terms that were designed at
inception to be racist
and in the context of good taste
probably shouldn't be used
there are white nails
i've seen a lot of white my time
repeated it
in the negative context one plane goes
down
he's president when brock longer fourth
in line pro tem purim look it up
so let's go to the first one here uh
i think american indian and there's a
subset here
so american indian is where we start off
and then we get to native aboriginal but
some activist groups they still say for
example that um
uh american indian is racist but it was
actually created by the way by
native americans as you know them first
nations people they were the ones
according according to 1995 to the u.s
census in the u.s census bureau okay
50 of american indians preferred the
term american india
36 only 37 preferred native american
remember at one point english meant
nothing to them
right it's true exactly we're supposed
to think this is racist
but this also includes aboriginal
indigenous is under this category this
really this really comes down to who you
ask okay no one seems to actually agree
even even to the point where now when i
was in school we learned to aboriginals
and in quebec we mainly had the iroquois
and the uh the algonquins
um but now native american is considered
offensive
what's needed is nothing less than a
total
renewal of the relationship between
canada
and first nations peoples
well we do have to let people from other
voices on this platform so uh
now we return to uh the world's silliest
country's
world's silliest prime minister to
explain
what term should be used prime minister
justin trudeau and as prime minister of
canada we'd like to officially apologize
to our aboriginal people
i'm sorry to our native american
population
again i apologize to our first nation
citizens
of this country we can't say first
nation
uh eskimo goes underneath there too by
the way that's considered a racial slur
and the reason here's one thing just
interesting that eskimos considered a
racial slur
and even the original reasoning i don't
think is that offensive people they
claim the tournament eater of raw meat
that was a big thing i think everyone in
the pitch room thought that this morning
i thought i thought yeah
um that's a good thing and then some
people thought it was like even if it's
even if it's beef at that point just
some people thought it came from the
latin word excommunicate
meaning the excommunicated ones because
they live up in no man's land
and the native people weren't christian
but the reality is it meant someone who
made snowshoes
it's practical yeah so many native
alaskans by the way still refer to
themselves as eskimos
you know why because the word inuit
isn't a part of the yupik languages
it's not even one of it's not even a
part of their language
we've created a term to be less
offensive to them yeah that
doesn't exist in their language the
original term one who makes snowshoes do
you know how native
many native american tribes
indian-american tribes know how they
name themselves
by what they did that's one who makes
teepees
and one who takes massive sh
that's that's exactly that's what they
did so we said oh well these people up
there the ones who make snowshoes
oh we call that eskimo works for me
next racist terms aren't oriental so in
2016 obama outlawed the usage of the
term oriental
in federal law because it was considered
racist uh
here's the thing the term is not at all
inherently racist it's an objective that
just means
of or pertaining to east asia i love
their trading company it is still
yes exactly so used that way by many by
the way it's a much more accurate term
than asian yeah that specifically
encompasses the orient right when people
say they mean east asia where nowadays
people when people say asian and you're
talking
you say well he's he is he asian indian
russian at least
parts of somewhere come on you know what
i mean
no he's not chinese japanese okinawan or
any variation thereof
oh okay so he's probably in yes
[Laughter]
oriental is not a racist term at all the
crusade against the term actually can
probably be linked to um edward said's
book orientalism in which he linked them
to like prejudice sort of outsider
examples of the oriental world based on
this that that's where it really comes
from right so right for the la times
actually jane tucciama
wrote literally it means of the orient
or the east as opposed to
of the occident or of the west last i
checked geographic origin is not a slur
if it were it would be wrong to label
people from mississippi as southerners
that's so brilliant and uh it's it's
mainly used today by older asians
just so you know they're the ones who
still use the term oriental more than
any
other example this is another example of
social justice warriors just
criminalizing a term
that many members of a group by the way
are perfectly fine with in the first
place
and it may turn out that their language
policing really only affects
asian americans who run self-described
oriental restaurants trading companies
things like that
i mean i mean these shylocks who took
advantage
of of these women and men while overseas
i stopped in singapore to meet with a
guy named lee kuan yew
who most foreign policy experts around
the world say
is the most the wisest man in the orient
okay well here's the thing shylocks
probably shouldn't have said and he had
no
no no orient but he wasn't wrong on
orient but we had to include it yeah
some bonus trivia on that bb yeah it was
the same day that he said those two
things
same day
the more you know which probably brings
us to our next one a term which is funny
you'll say well aren't we allowed to say
this because no no it's reverse
colored people but now it's just people
of color see it confused but colored
colored is it terminal was outlawed for
a long time the naacp to me is
hysterical
still one of the biggest actives
organizations the black community that's
the name so according to james williams
and naacp spokesperson by the way rachel
dolezal yeah was naacp yeah
and a lot of pamphlets but really she
had a lot of college expenses to redo
yeah
wrote times change and terms change
racial designations go through phases at
one time negro was accepted at an
earlier time colored and so on
colored people was not offensive it
became black americans and now we want
to say people of color
this is the the the reason this matters
is because there is a war on words and
we'll get to
bring this back around at the end people
are trying to control language rather
than address the ideological
problems with racism another term
chinamen
this is one a lot of people think that's
right so chinese american historians
have remarked the term [ __ ] actually
it
originated when census takers they were
unable to gather information
and this is what they used they said
should not be considered racist and
intent it came back from a time when
they couldn't
they're like giant man from china man
yeah makes sense
sounds pretty reasonable i am ohio man
and guess who used this to refer to
themselves
chinese people chinese americans for
example chinese leader norman
asing described himself as a china man a
republican
a free institution in his 1852 letter to
the governor of california are you going
to let someone who's an
ass determine what is racist you know
i'm afraid that at some point we won't
be able to use the term mexican
because some of the dude that mexican
there don't speak no english and took
our jobs i'm like
you're saying it in a way that's kind of
a pejor i hear mexican now like oh geez
i hope there are no mexicans around
it almost means george oh well he he
wrote this but he's been he was started
editing out
[ __ ] for chinese and the new
editions of his books
and this is how silly that we've become
oh my gosh terms englishmen frenchman
irishman they're not considered racist
but [ __ ] is i don't know i don't get
it okay negro
negro is the next one now i know i just
wanted to just boom boom there's the
cold water
the word negro we think it's so
offensive and i got in trouble and i'm
saying it i said it in a car once and
there's a black kid in the car and i
remember
i said it i would have been we were
carpooling i said it specifically
because i thought it was less offensive
than black
yeah and the reason was because i'm i'm
french and you know
anyway latin the romance languages that
come from first the word negro it's
simply directed
latin word black it was very common
until the end of the 60s
right and what actually the term what's
the term in german it's very similar
it's also a roman language so the german
term bp is and i can always say this
because i have a director
yeah yeah it's uh [ __ ] yeah you can't
say that with a dragon but i want you to
say it again to make sure i heard that
it's [ __ ] yeah how's this how's that
spelled n-e-g-e-r
and we have and we had a q oh my god
very indie we had a candy called
nigacoos which translate to
negro kiss and that was outlaw
but i still grew up on that it was
outlawed well they just changed it for i
guess
what's what is what's it called now it's
now called chamkus
what does that mean um chocolate foam
kiss
you just show all the chocolate people
yeah they're you know that's better
the nine black people in germany are
like we remember what you said
social reformers the abolitionists use
the term negro to describe themselves
frederick douglass as an example
slade even put at least until 1966 it
was used by many it was mainly used by
african americans
that that's the point negro is a perfect
example of this it was never designed no
i
the n-word right spend you better watch
out the n-word was designed to be
derogatory
okay that's what people need to
understand and you'll notice a trend
with all of these words and the reason
put this out there is that you're no
longer afraid
of losing words you're no longer afraid
of words being weaponized
you shouldn't go out to someone who says
i really don't like being called negro
that offends me and go negro [ __ ] nino
you really that's not the point of this
the point is
the trend is today's pc term for a group
of people it becomes tomorrow's racist
term and that's because the strategy the
left has it's the same thing with
transgender lgbtq aip
it's the same thing with socialism to
democratic socialism it's their strategy
of changing words
rather than dealing with the ideology or
the information behind them their goal
is to police language
period that is the end goal their goal
is to label certain terms racist so they
can label more and more people racist
bigots
precisely so they don't have to address
the points remember when we said that
someone said you're committing
for example if someone were to say oh
man nice shiner to a black guy
because he had gotten into a fight and
had a black eye and he were to say what
did you say are you calling me a shiner
i i would apologize i wouldn't think he
would do that i think he would be like
oh
oh yeah i'm sorry about two and then
some white lady would come i'd be like
right you should be
yeah you should be feminist would be
like why you committed violence against
him because i read the article once
by miss finishing him he's totally mad
can't you see that
seriously now if someone would say to me
like what did you mean by that
that's a perfect example of someone
trying to weaponize or they know what i
meant by it
i meant black eye just like when you say
oh gosh if you get mad
you say you're start you're you're let's
say burger king and i don't know they
happen to have black staff but they get
your order wrong three times ago
what is it here at this particular what
is with you people like what do you mean
you people i have no talents for that i
don't apologize now if i said something
insensitive
if i deliberately used a racial slur or
told a joke that was off color and went
too far you say listen i'm sorry or if
it's a friend whose feelings i don't
want to hurt even though i
don't think i was wrong of course they
will but the point is you cannot allow
the left to take control
and weaponize words the reason for this
the reason for the ever expanding
lexicon of words that you can't say
which are often more accurate were
created by these ethnic groups
themselves
is because they want to be able to label
more people
racist homophobic sexist bigoted
transphobic intersex phobic
take your pic phobic or wrist at the end
of the day
and they can't do that through the
information they can't do that through
factual
information they can't do it through the
history of the terminology as we've gone
through they just have to do it by
saying
don't say that word if you say it we're
going to destroy your career
and then we over here there's michael
richards kind of had that one coming
we've turned the tables on
al gore and used the internet to our
advantage if you like this video
subscribe
by hitting the subscribe button or the
notification bell next to it because
subscribing isn't enough watch one of
these other videos and uh you know
listen you can
you can stick around you don't have to
but here's the thing the fact that
you're still listening to me saying
stick around
as i say stick around and you're
sticking around we just added another ad
you just made me feel more sense